[Music]
so one of the things I'm going to do and
get you to do every time we play boy has
a lot to do with a certain relationship
to what's around you which is funny cuz
it kind of brings you into the space
around you I happen to be on a small
lake above st. gallen Switzerland so
yeah
we're facing this way to my right I've
got a floaty float to my left I've got a
big tree straight in front of me I've
got the dock and straight behind me I've
got the seating so this helps me stay
oriented and consistent in what I do so
if I'm trying to learn something new I
can think to myself okay I'm always
going to start with my POI spending
forwards towards the floaty float and
I'm gonna pass them maybe up behind my
hips so if I remember that and I stay
consistent it's gonna be much easier for
me to learn and I'm also becoming aware
of my tracks and so how the direction
I'm spinning my POIs oh I'm spinning
them straight towards floaty floats like
they're train tracks if I turn around
they're flying straight away from the
big tree like they're on tracks you're
not on a lake in st. Gallen probably
you're probably somewhere else
so what we're always gonna have to do is
I'm the whatever I am I will pick my
directions and you will have to have
your directions at home so maybe you're
in your living room and straight in
front of you you've got your computer
screen that you're watching these videos
on tear right you've got the kitchen to
your left
you've got the exits and behind you
you've got the sofa as we do this
another important thing is how I show
you what we're doing so often if I'm
facing you I'm gonna say Mirror me and
I'll say take your right hand right and
so now I've got my left up obviously but
it's like we're a mirror image so you're
facing me like this I'm facing you like
this so if I say okay and reach your
right hand this way you're facing me and
you'll go like this
so together we're doing a mirror image
so maybe I'll say take your right hand
stretch it out and make a big circle
over the top like this do this with me
and you'll see what I mean so it's like
I'm your mirror you're my mirror now if
I turn around I'll switch mirror you
will be flocking together so I'll say
take your right hand and now I'm also
taking my right hand this will make
sense don't worry as we go and I'll say
take your right hand and switch over the
top so if I'm doing this you're flocking
with me you're doing the same thing if I
turn around I'll switch to mirroring you
so you wouldn't switch you keep doing
the same thing I switch for you because
if we're facing this way some things are
obvious we're facing this way some other
things are obvious and a lot of the
lessons will proceed like this and I'll
always try to make it clear either I'll
say okay mirror me take you maybe take
your left hand right and so we're
mirroring or I'll say do this with me
take your left hand so using these
principles of having these four clear
directions mirroring and flocking we'll
go through all our lessons and it should
make a lot of sense just stick with me
and you'll see what I mean
[Music]